hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
tagen welt ich habe heute ein kleines
tutorial für euch und zwar möchte ich
euch zeigen wie ich meine rosen für die
verlobungs torte hergestellt habe und
die verlobung startet die werde ich euch
auch bald zusammen schneiden will ich
einfach die einzelne dekoelemente
vorgestellt habe ich möchte nämlich
nicht dass dieses eine video meter lang
wird
ich habe jetzt eine rose hergestellt die
nicht zu schwer ist in der herstellung
es gibt ja verschiedene methoden man
kann eine rose ohne irgendwie werkzeug
herstellen
die wollte ich jetzt nicht wählen weil
ich schon wollte dass sie etwas
besonders aussieht und deswegen habe ich
jetzt eine hose gewählt die mit
einfachen ausstellern hergestellt wird
und diese ausstecher gibt es zum
beispiel auch bei mir im shop wenn man
aber diese ausstecher nicht habe und
sich auch keine kaufen will kann man das
ganze auch mit runden ausstecher machen
das hat dann den ähnlichen effekt diese
rosen könnt ihr übrigens schon ein paar
tage oder wochen vor eurer torte
herstellen
die trockenen dann einfach durch ihr
müsst ihr dann nur so verpacken dass
kein sonnenlicht drankommt weil
ansonsten die farbe etwas auslassen kann
und dann können dass sie einfach am tag
der torte oder des ereignisses einfach
herausnehmen und auf die torte
draufsetzen und ich würde sagen ich
statt einfach mal mit dem video und
hoffe dass ganz viel spaß dabei gehabt
ich habe jetzt hier ein stück blüten
passte das fertige bild passte man kann
die aber auch selber machen und ich
werde sie jetzt mit der lebensmittel
farbe rot von de cuba kein das ist eine
passende farbe und es empfehle ich euch
auch das er die blüten passte mit
passten farbe einfärbt mit von dort kam
die rosen nicht so gut machen weil
einfach da von dort aus rollbar ist
die konsistenz der blüten paste ist so
dass wenn ihr dran zieht und sie
auseinander heißt dass sie nicht in die
länge zieht sondern dass sie schnelle
reis und so sollte es ja auch sein
zuerst müssen wir jetzt das mittelstück
von der hose formen und dieses könnt ihr
auch schon vorbereiten und auch lagern
so dass ihr jederzeit rosen herstellen
könnt dafür brauchen wir jetzt gleich
große stücke ich habe jetzt mal drei
gemacht und für eine rose braucht ihr
nur ein stück dieses rollt ihr dann zu
einer kugel zusammen und die kugel hat
dann etwa einen durchmesser von 1 5 bis
2 cm je nachdem wie groß eure rose wert
diese kugel vom tier dann zu einem kegel
in dem ihr eine seite mit beiden händen
etwas zusammenrückt und so werde ich
jetzt auch meine restlichen kegel
herstellen für insgesamt drei rosen
diesen kegel müsst ihr dann richtig
durch trocknen lassen also den könnt ihr
auch gerne schon 12 tage vorher
herstellen und von der größe her muss
auch so sein dass er in den kleinsten
ausstecher reinpasst und etwa 5 mm
kleiner ist und es sind die drei
ausstecher die ich bei mir im shop habe
mit diesen kann man nicht nur rosen
sondern auch andere blumen herrscht wenn
dann die mittleren teile getrocknet sind
könnt ihr euch die restliche blüten
passte nehmen und ganz dünn ausrollen
also für dünn wie es geht und es klappt
am besten wenn ihr die blüten passte auf
etwas becker stärke aus gold mit diesen
kleinen ausrutscher
dann nehmen wir uns den kleinsten der
drei ausstecher und stechen daraus zwei
blätter pro rose aus
und da ist es am besten wenn ihr wisst
wie viele rosen ihr herstellen wollt
könnt ihr gleich parallel arbeiten und
jeden schritt auch direkt für die
anderen rosen mitmachen diese
rosenblätter legt ihr dann auf dieses
schaumstoff kate das eignet sich super
dazu um dann mit diesem gold holt also
mit dem ball werkzeug die enden
auszudünnen natürlich könnte man die
rosen jetzt auch so lassen
aber wenn die rosen an den rändern etwas
ausgedünnt werden sehen sie einfach
etwas echter aus und haben diese
natürliche wellen mit drin
dann nehmt ihr einfach etwas zucker
kleber dass es mit cmc hergestellt und
bepinselt das untere drittel des großen
platz mit dem kleber dann nehmt ihr euch
dieses innere stück und legt es auf euer
platz drauf unten könnt ihr die spitze
mal einklappen und dran kleben und dann
wird zuerst die eine seite angebracht
und daran geklebt und die andere seite
dann drumherum geredet
und da müsst ihr aufpassen dass die
spitze des keils verdeckt ist und oben
wie rose dann so fast ganz zu ist so
läge dann dieses mittlere stück auf das
zweite platz und geht da auch zuerst
unten die spitze an
und dann von rechts und links drückend
leben wir dann dieses blatt am beiden
seiten fest
und dieses mittlere stück laste jetzt
auch etwa zwei stunden rund damit an
trocknen kann
und dann arbeiten wir da gleich weiter
anschließend brauchen wir wieder den
kleinsten ausstecher und benötigten
dieses mal drei bier tabulose und auch
hier ständig wieder gleich mehr aus für
die anderen hosen und diese decke ich
dann mit meiner silikon mutter ab damit
sie nicht austrocknen des blätter werden
als erster von der batter stärke befreit
das geht mit hilfe eines pinsels ganz
gut
und dann werden wieder die enten
ausgedünnten dem rollstuhl
bei diesen blätter machen lässt so dass
wir einen zahnstocher nehmen und die
blätter etwas nach außen wickeln
so sehen die blütenblätter einfach etwas
natürlicher aus wie ihr sehen könnt
und das mache ich jetzt bei zwei
blättern auf der einen seite und bei den
dritten blatt wenn ich beide seiten
die blätter werden dann auch mit etwas
zucker kleber bepinselt am unteren
drittel
und dann nehme ich mir auch schon das
erste platz und leg ist anm eine rose
dran und wickle es drum herum lasse aber
den rand offenstehen und wickle da
gleich das nächste blatt mit allen und
so wirklich jetzt alle drei blätter drum
herum so dass sie eben ineinander
drinstecken so könnt ihr zum beispiel
diese kleine rose verwenden um eben auch
mal geschlossene rosen auf der torte
anzubringen
die müsst ihr jetzt auch etwa zwei
stunden trocknen lassen und könnt dann
weiter verfahren
als nächstes nehme ich jetzt den
mittleren ausstecher und stiche prognose
jetzt fünf blätter aus diese werden
wieder ausgedünnt und dieses mal werden
drei blätter auf einer seite nach außen
gewählt mit dem zahnstocher und zwei
blätter werden auf beiden seiten nach
außen gewohnt die blätter bestreichen
dann wieder mit etwas kleber und beginne
dann wieder außen die blätter
aneinanderzureihen und immer einen seite
offen zu lassen und das nächste
blütenblatt viel schreit zu spicken
unten geht es dann ganz leicht
angedrückt
und auch diese rose lassen wir jetzt für
etwa zwei stunden antrocknen damit sie
beim antrocknen jetzt nicht
auseinanderfällt werde ich sie jetzt in
ein kleines gläschen hinein geben da
habe ich jetzt ein bisschen küchenpapier
reingelegt und jetzt kann ich etwas
küchenpapier nehmen und die rose in form
bringen und zwar legt sie einfach
zwischen die einzelnen blätter hinein
und werde die hose so hinlegen wie ich
sie später haben möchte und so trocknet
sie dann auch fest und so las ich die
rose mindestens zwei stunden besser aber
einen kompletten tag trocknen und am
nächsten tag nehme ich dann den größten
ausstecher und stechen mit damit nochmal
fünf blätter aus diese werden dann
natürlich auch etwas ausgedünnt und mit
dem zahnstocher jeweils drei stück an
einer seite und zwei an beiden seiten
eingeräumt
am besten dreht ihr jetzt die rose über
kopf und deswegen ist es auch wichtig
das zu trocken ist und dann könnt ihr
die blätter über kopf auf die rose dran
kleben und zum schluss setzt sich die
fertige rose wieder auf etwas
küchenpapier und werde dann mit den
übrigen küchenpapier streifen die rose
wieder zurechtrücken und sie so komplett
austrocknen lassen
ich habe nun auch etwas weiße blüten
passte mit grün und dem schwarz
eingefärbt um ein schönes blattgrün zu
erhalten und mit hilfe des blood
ausstellers habe ich jetzt ein paar
grüne blätter ausgestochen
diese haben jetzt noch keine prägung und
die prägung werde ich es mit hilfe
meines schneider mädchens hineindrücken
in dem ich einmal die innere oder
markieren und dann kleine feine adern
nach außen markiere damit die blätter
jetzt nicht so flach trocknen lasse ich
sehe auch eine zusammengeschnitten
alufolie trocknen und wer möchte kann
die blätter nach dem trocknen mit etwas
pulver farbe anmalen so bekommen sie
einfach eine natürliche die prüfer farbe
gibt es übrigens auch bei uns im shop
und die werde ich euch unten in der
infobox verlinken
die fertigen rosen werde ich dann auch
mit etwas pulver farbe bemalen und zwar
nehme ich hier für etwas rot und etwas
dunkleres oder einfach um die
blütenblätter am rand anzumalen
und zum schluss werden jetzt noch aus
grüna flügen passende die kelchblätter
ausgesprochen und das mache ich einfach
mit so einem lilien ausstecher und auch
diese werde ich mit der bolt ruhe etwas
ausdünnen und dann auch mit dem ball von
außen nach innen durch jedes blatt
fahren
so bekommt nämlich dieses bleibt eine
wölbung nach innen
wer möchte kann dann noch einen
zwischenschritt machen und die blätter
etwas einschneiden damit sie echte
aussehen aber ich bin nicht der vorgang
ist gar nicht so wichtig weil man die
kelchblätter sowieso nicht so aussieht
diese werden dann mit etwas kleber an
der hose befestigt ich würze aber nicht
bis zur spitze angeben sondern die
spitzen dann etwas nach außen formen und
die rose könnt ihr dann entweder so
lassen oder ihr könnt sie noch mit etwas
back trance play besprühen damit sie
einen glanz bekommen wir schon gesehen
habt habe ich meine rosen jetzt ohne
draht hergestellt viele methoden sind
nämlich so dass man trat benutzt um die
äußeren blätter anzubringen damit
schöner aussieht aber ich mag es nicht
so gerne wenn man trat mit in der torte
mit drin hat das verwende ich nur wenn
es wirklich nötig ist und deswegen habe
ich hier bei meiner hose auftrat
verzichtet hier möchte ich euch jetzt
einmal den unterschied zeigen zwischen
den blumen die ich schon besprüht habe
mit dem bug transparent und denen die
eben
gesperrt sind und zwar kann man hier
jetzt deutlich sehen dass diese blumen
richtig schönen glanz und die rote farbe
auch richtig schön vorkommt also das
sieht man ihr so gut dass jedes rot
einfach nicht so schöne vorkommt und
hier strahlt es einfach und genau so ist
es auch bei diesen blättern hier dieses
eine was besprüht wurde es ganz schön
und jedes andere was wirklich matsch
liegt und deswegen besprechen es all
meine blumen ganz sanft mit diesen bug
trends gray und genau so mache ich das
natürlich auch mit den blättern
und man sieht natürlich auch ganz
deutlich den unterschied zwischen den
blättern die mit der prüfer farbe bemalt
wurden und besprüht wurden und zwischen
der rückseite die eben einfach nur aus
den blüten passte bestand also so sieht
der unterschied aus wenn ich keine
puffer farbe genommen hätte und kein bug
transfer wird so aussehen und so hat
eben diesen effekt und sieht natürlich
viele räder aus
ich hoffe dass sich dieses video
geholfen hat und hier auch mal band eine
rose herstellen bettet ich bitte euch
das rezept für die blüten passte unten
in der infobox verlinken und dort
verlinkt ich euch aber auch die
feldabwehr modelliermasse also diese
fertige blüten passte dies zu kaufen
gibt in meinem shop
ich arbeite eigentlich nur noch mit ihr
weil da auch kein rohes ei weiß drin ist
und weil ich einfach so die zeit spare
und die masse nicht erst herstellen muss
und ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen und ich freue
mich natürlich darüber wenn ihr mir
fotos auf instagram oder facebook
schickt die schon immer ganz gerne an
und ich werde jetzt übrigens eine video
reihe machen mit kate basics und wettern
immer in ganz kurzen videos zeigen was
für einzelne schritte eben notwendig
sind um eine torte herzustellen und ich
fühle mich jetzt um die samira blog.de
genau da gibt es die rezepte ja zum
nachlesen kicker können sie auch gucken
auch bei kita gibt es nur kinderserien
genau und ich glaube wir gehen jetzt ein
bisschen an die frische luft wie ich
freue mich aufs nächste mal fußballs